yeah lock him to this video yeah this is
a new dual commentary video so you will
get both players commentating on the
game yeah and this is against Finn's
Finn's is a national master him from the
US John Bartholomew he's got a YouTube
channel as well obviously and he also
will release a video on that so it's the
dual commentary form and that is very
popular on the channel make sure to
check out John some video of this game
and also his channel in general is very
much worth watching it is pretty new but
it has some lots of good Blitzer videos
with common so he's some it's basically
if you like my stuff you will like it as
well I'm pretty sure about it so um yeah
check it out so we got a Queens gambit
declined here what we should be 79 87
against Bishop f4 this is a line that I
play from time to time I have had
studied it quite um intensely in ah what
was that 2011 or something like that and
that felt that is it is a pretty good
choice for for black if you want the
solid position and it is some indeed a
very solid choice let's see what to do
here I can take c3 ham and 4b takes and
the Queens gambit declined is one of the
classical answers to deform and it has
hood its ground for for ages really here
I'm getting a pretty good development
I'm not sure about be six though I could
have played Queen a five as well but
this shouldn't be too bad he may be
happy for her white has a slide
slide them superior soup while it's a
difficult word superiority in the center
and this extra porn but okay I don't
have a bad piece and no worm particular
direct problem huh interesting i wonder
if i should take on d4 or not ctx might
be a little bit better for him
not clear rook c8 I think Queen a4 might
be an issue it's a bit bit annoying this
move Queen d5 has also move that comes
into consideration but he's got see 494
it's not doing much this Queen a form of
a sir is annoying me I don't know it
kind of unsure how to proceed this is
not an easy decision to take or not to
take yeah I think she takes deism what
I'm expecting here and not eat eggs he
takes should be okay I think yeah and he
I had a screen a forum was a kind of
problematic i was thinkin Queen d5 now
so that I can actually go to a 5 in any
cases of harassment answers Queen a5 is
a is a square maybe Roxy 7 i'm not quite
sure note that this is a 5 plus 1 game
so we have one second increment to make
sure that we actually can play chess to
the end and any simple end game can be
played to a logical end and this is
blitz this is a blitz rating yeah he got
almost 3000 and I don't play that rating
at all so minus a little bit low well
3000 is high I mean he's also got about
2500 in the five-minute pool so really
really strong blitz player yeah II for
him he wants to play you for him he
definitely wants to do that
and possibly create form but before I
mean I can take Bishop c4 is this this
is the second idea should see for 24 mm
and then nope no more heart you cannot
attack the Queen after that okay that
looks looks kind of ugly Bishop d8 but I
see no refutation at the moment maybe
our maybeee for first efore nitey foyer
here thought I can go to e4 actually
there's always the maid on g2 so night
g5 or 92 are not working maybe he could
play maybe you could have played before
here efore night takes then Bishop c4
maybe that was possible
yeah he has gotten in this move now but
is it helping very much I don't know I
don't know rook c8 looks useful and I
always have Queen 85 as a possible
square yeah okay double attacking a
seven or eight seven at first here hmm
yeah a 5-4 Bishop d7 yeah it's it's it's
not a very nice position 95-year 95
possible okay now I get in Bishop d7 for
the moment okay I thought actually I
could play rook see Bishop e7 expert I
cannot because of rooks e7 but ok the
same morning yeah yeah I know I know I'm
kind of used to it this time issues I
actually thought I would get some
counter play here but you can always
push push me back with Bishop d3 hmm not
easy but I can go no I cannot for 995
okay so it doesn't mind he doesn't mind
Bishop 87 Bishop a7 rookie a drug see
seven years yeah and there's also the
back rank issues you should be a Sam
Luca a drug c7 should be okay
for him wow what an ugly game exists so
we can can also play rook c7 maybe I
just attacking d7 yeah
I have there any way out of this that
doesn't look good right there should be
three probably simply that Bishop d3 and
I really don't don't know where to go
okay I mean why does definitely better
here as well that's no no big no big
question it's basically just a pawn and
I have no particular counterclaim and
he's got d5 but I needed to do something
the only little chance there is left is
some check hoping that I can somehow
reduce the material so that win is not
possible but it's very unlikely that
this is going to happen Jim need to get
to the a pawn of it which is kind of
difficult anyway to the apron probably
not yeah it's getting this check on the
phone and I only have seven seconds but
II for Hanks which is kind of nice hmm
hmm somehow is still existing here and
this in this game maybe I can actually
hold this together here and this is this
is a draw I think you cannot cannot
zucca swung me maybe can I cannot wow
that was immensely lucky immensely lucky
were completely busted here when I
started to learning to use an enormous
amount of time okay we'll do a second
game now again then starting we can we
look at both games in one go so that we
really have the match going here we then
both can decide how long we want to
analyze and the thing
the Slav yes I have played the Slav
against him in the in one of the live
broadcasts one game but we get a
different a different line now
transposing to a semi Slav this is an
interesting line can wear black tries to
get in quick counter play on this
diagonal here and I have forgotten how
it works I have to go to h4 yeah this is
a very quick account to play on on my
right the on this diagonal a3 I believe
is right that's a tactical line g5i
forgotten i ever got now it is working
the exact move order i think this is
okay for white but i don't remember
exactly oh we just castles that's um
that's surprising actually because it
kind of firm yeah it makes the whole
thing a little bit questionable what
like did I think um we should be three
on not I can also casts a long
yeah this is the easiest probably tried
to directly unpin it it almost forces
the trades now night XD to I can take
before when a piece I think so he has to
take Bishop takes 22 or is there some
technical way for him to allow me to
take on e4 I don't think so okay so he
has to take them and this now I'm is
from a structural point of view
fantastic for me but the question is is
there something dynamic going on that is
a problem I don't see it at the moment I
mean of course he can take and play this
end game where it's just worse but it's
not very happy very nice prospect yeah
the question is with what piece I'll
take with the book having a quick
look-see to in store because I think
that'd be six is something that might
happen yeah ok so I'm going to go back
to g3 hem having an eye on a c5 push if
you take see for now d takes Bishop
takes a five is impossible due to the
back rank made at the end and my general
plan is like Bishop e2 King be one Luke
c 1 f 3 and this this kind of thing he
might play Bishop a six
okay i think i will take so that you
cannot play Bishop a six so easily and
ansan-si takes di will play king be one
ok this one yeah this opens up his his
bishop but well this the sea porn is a
target so I still think this should be
quite okay for me Bishop d3 first or
well he will play c5 I guess I wonder if
be for something higher but maybe he can
go for something like b5 really quickly
I go here this is interesting if he go
see 5 this Bishop b5 actually with some
nasty pins going on yeah he had to do
you do that and now we're thinking even
before as a move I ok I can i still have
Bishop b5 so ok but I cannot really go
without this in the long run doubling on
the sea foam or what so had before yeah
these are the kind of positions where
you need to be precise really precise to
keep an advantage because if we are not
precise it might evaporate Bishop d3 is
not bad though he has a problem we
cannot easily play c5 yes this is what I
was thinking 90 forward still ok go here
for whoopsie one
94 book c1 and I keep preventing c5
going for b4 b5 at the end and it wasn't
the only possible way to play but it was
a i think a decent one keeps some
advantage
yep a so this is even clarified so
before you this is the IDM going for be
five I only have one little weakness on
f2 which is easily protected from the
rooks oh look f six or something is
basically not not doing much and this is
kind of a textbook position for our
Queens gambit type of positions now I
can go a4 a5 this is a direct way to
play I will do that he may be played we
can play b5 here trying to shut the
whole thing down it's the kind of a
really ugly move but a4 a5 is quite
substantial if he allows that it will be
very ugly and a 5 I go b5 and I will
break up the C file break open break
open break up I don't know that's a very
difficult position to the event yeah
maybe he has to play the super ugly be
5f
yeah that's really ugly stuff if you
want if you need to play be five but
it's it's it's really really really ugly
yeah I can also play a five immediately
but i'm not sure if i want to want to do
that yeah that's assets counterplay g4g
5s maybe an idea I'm not quite sure I
want to hook a one here first I and now
I can flick in g 4g for age six not sure
about it also f voice as possible but ok
let's start with this first I can always
also recapture with the C porn so yeah
maybe ash maybe I don't get anywhere
here if I if I ever Teague on b5 Bishop
c8 Bishop f5 is his his idea
I should start with this actually so
that I have g5 yes so now Bishop f
Bishop c8 he will attack this and I need
to be ready for f3 here so that you
cannot play Bishop f5 ok I'm doing here
so bishop CA Tai go f3 time morning yeah
i think i have to close this anyway now
let's see what I can do with h6 this is
a new target and age 6 ok let's think
about it for a moment you three is of
course a source for counter play now I
do and I don't get anywhere there I
really don't i have to play you for him
I think open up against c6 maybe this
first yeah d4 hangs I have to cover that
ok tries to go to d5 if I understand
f F or maybe GI a vm okay yeah he has
defended as well I probably made some
mistakes and my tries to increase the
puck in crease the pressure but he fell
no I'm getting somewhere I thought check
got one Chang check putting everything
on dark squares first okay check I'm
just running to the to the and pawns on
the twin side he cannot defend them wow
black resigns it was tough yeah it was a
very bad position somehow all of the
opening that he got him very well very
thankless task to replay this I probably
didn't play it totally correctly but
yeah very lucky result here I think yeah
I could have easily lost this match and
in fact I wanted one and a half so hmm
quite quite surprising at the end that
I'm that I managed to get a get a win
iam okay so let's have a look at the
games I will pull up the the first game
at first okay so let's have a look at
this game now where I was black yeah
this is all fairly standard stuff in
this in this opening may be here I did
something wrong i mean the the ease this
looks quite quite normal you know I
didn't want to do that because I thought
this might be might be good for him
but I have the Shakya I forgot about
this idea this this is the reason why I
had some slight issues in the opening I
was a bit surprised about Bishop g3 but
this would have been good he has to take
with the pawn and then I have a pretty
decent position against the iqp I mean
they're not that I'm better anything but
I think I'm definitely all right this is
Bishop Vaughn g3 is not so well placed
okay okay this isn't terrible but it's
probably something form for wide I ad5
as an interesting yeah interesting move
IAM difficult to answer that he's got
this threat and this thread blue not
good it was a early possibility for
white and t i think it should be it
should be decent nothing great but
decent yeah this i went here i briefly
thought that maybe this is possible this
looks kind of curious right i am the
computer actually says i can I should
sacrifice the Queen now oh yeah the
queen is trapped I saw that during the
game but is this is rather funny both
rooks are hanging and this is ok for
black assess the comp stop fish I only
saw that efore was possible but he
didn't go for it but we tweeted yeah it
still keeps slight edge but I think I'm
probably making mistakes here now this
is this is getting very substantial now
for what with I mean and here's multiple
ways to keep this big advantage I think
what he did was perfectly good it was
just somehow it was somehow always he
had rook c8 certainly helps but the
circle of means that when you don't see
a win you'll be direct when you play it
because it looks simple I thought this
and I didn't really know what
then maybe here on b6 hang so yeah I
mean no doubt that he was winning in
this game does this end game is also
very good for white but it it is not as
yeah I'm okay it is also really winning
we should be seven hours strong my night
is very embarrassing situation cannot go
anywhere yeah well this was I had more
lives than aniket Oh what is the kind of
figure for a figure of speech am not
using this was like a miracle I was also
down on time yeah somehow I stumbled
into the opposite colored bishops yeah
and here I mean here it's not not that
easy anymore maybe it's very dry shuttle
ready isn't this a draw I can go d6
actually this is good yes sir he's far
too quickly and he gets the pawn to d6
and can go here yeah it is probably
still winning oh wow yeah this is the
draw now yeah I really stumbled to draw
this game I mean always lost basically
and somehow I somewhere I didn't lose I
don't know I don't know really ok let's
check the second game briefly put it on
second game perhaps so ok the second
game yeah this laughs with Quincy to
check and yeah this is an interesting
way for counter play I had forgotten the
theory three I think I think this is
played now this is how it is played
Bishop g3 and then on g4 I can I think I
castle long if i'm not mistaken this is
this is a theoretical line remembering
this correctly it looks totally bonkers
but i think it's okay okay well he
played this and now i mean this is this
is this is already not good I mean the
best that you can do i think is really
what he played ya can take and now you
only have a choice between various evils
you can take on the two or you can hear
what else is there can play an ugly move
like a five year which flaw i mean i
play a three probably and white is just
better I've got two bishops he's got
tons of weak squares dark squares yeah
this is the kind of check yeah trying to
hold this slightly uncomfortable
position but I think I did a decent job
here playing playing quite precisely b6
is logical and the capture I think also
yeah this is also what stockfish gifts
and here here Bishop d3 9f six what
stockfish now gives H forth for the
movements that I wants to preserve the
bishop I don't know what is h1 to play
Bishop I'd wants to play this and then
it's actually interesting and it wants
to prevent g5 very interesting no now
edge for didn't cross my mind an
interesting way to play okay well I went
here I was seeing this position here and
I thought wow this is so one sided maybe
maybe he should play a five year trying
to hinder the before thing here Wow here
it gets really ugly at be five is the
movie i hate he took almost a minute
because this is the kind of move that
yeah
they'd really young acknowledges that
you're suffering for the rest of the
game and you will never ever win and
probably lose yeah I know maybe I should
have played a 5 immediately I thought
that it makes sense to one to keep some
options with the a file but he will
probably take with the sea pawn and then
I haven't gained anything now yeah and
I'm not sure about about g6 by the way
but okay I feel like he defended this
well and it's it's it's really
uncomfortable but I think he defended
well and I went with this because I
thought that maybe there is no further
way forward it's it's difficult with
this time efore looks yeah maybe it's
too early it's a very one-sided thing of
course yeah you can easily see that I
can try to help alter the pawn structure
in various ways f/4g five or whatever
but before I think this is okay I mean
however however i'm going to make
progress without the move okay so went
down there and i think black should
should be able to defend this now
somehow it is very uncomfortable that I
went to yeah and now I could get
something here on the Kings side with
their form yeah but f5 is giving away
the porn but it's of course you are you
defending defending defending all the
time it's not much fun it's an
interesting question if this is a drawer
if this is this is this is losing from
black he has to go Bishop g7
this is actually a direct win with d5 I
i can see that stockfish gives gives
this is a direct win probably it is yes
yeah this is this is definitely a win
because of this thing this is the
problem of this Queen side when I said
that b5 is kind of acknowledging that
you're suffering it's because of those
things and the pawns are on light
squares and TM you will win you will
witness why'd you will win the endgame
all pawns are in light squares and this
is this is unbearable yeah like here
let's say here here here yeah I mean
this doesn't look good but what else are
you doing if you do this is Bishop d5
coming you get zoosk Montier that is
this and what now this actually if King
is 6 Bishop h3 check yeah this and I'm
invading really a terrible end game yeah
well this this she gave away upon and
well I I gladly took it check and check
yeah putting this on dark squares first
and this is trading down to the winning
bishops endgame yeah I think this was
okay and I always had some pressure it's
not clear maybe at one point it could
have defended this could have defended
this successfully but it was always
really difficult to do so i guess the
fair result of this match would have
been at 11 so my win here was pretty
okay but the first game i could have
lost like on a ton of occasions so i
guess lucky metric to him yeah i really
encourage you to check out john's
version of this this comment read will
be very enlightening i guess and i
really i watched a ton of his blitz
games and its really good so go out and
go ahead go and check out his channel
well thanks for watching hi